Hi.
In this problem, we'll get a
chance to see the usefulness
of conditioning in helping us
to calculate quantities that
would otherwise be difficult
to calculate.
Specifically, we'll be using
the law of iterated
expectations and the law
of total variance.
Before we get started, let's
just take a quick moment to
interpret what these two
laws are saying.
Really, what it's saying is,
in order to calculate the
expectation or the variance of
some random variable x, if
that's difficult to do,
we'll instead attack
this problem in stages.
So the first stage is, we'll
condition on some related
random variable, y.
And the hope is that by
conditioning on this and
reducing it to this conditional
universe, the
expectation of x will be
easier to calculate.
Now, recall that this
conditional expectation is
really a random variable, which
is a function of the
random variable y.
So what we've done is we first
average out x given some y.
What remains is some new random
variable, which is a
function of y.
And now, what we have is
randomness in y, which will
then average out again to get
the final expectation of x.
OK, so in this problem, we'll
actually see an example of how
this plays out.
One more thing before we get
started that's useful to
recall is if y is a uniform
random variable, distributed
between a and b, then the
variance of y is b minus a
squared over 12, and the
expectation of y is just a
midpoint, a plus b over 2.
All right, so let's get started
on the problem.
So what we have is we have a
stick of some fixed length, l,
and what we do is we break
it uniformly at random.
So what we do is we choose a
point uniformly at random
along this stick.
And we break it there, and then
we keep the left portion
of that stick.
So let's call the length of this
left portion after the
first break random variable y.
So it's random because
the point where
we break it is random.
And then what we do is we
repeat this process.
We'll take this left side of
the stick that's left.
And we'll pick another point,
uniformly at random, along
this left remaining side.
And we'll break it again,
and keep the left
side of that break.
And we'll call that the length
of the final remaining piece,
x, which again is random.
The problem is really asking
us to calculate the
expectation of variance of x.
So at first, it seems difficult
to do, because the
expectation and variance of x
depends on where you break it
the second time and also where
you break it the first time.
So let's see if conditioning
can help us here.
So the first thing that we'll
notice is that, if we just
consider y, the length of the
stick after the first break,
it's actually pretty easy to
calculate the expectation and
variance of y.
Because y, when you think about
it, is actually just the
simple uniform in a variable,
uniformly distributed between
0 and l, the length
of the stick.
And this is because we're told
that we choose the point of
the break uniformly at random
between 0 and l.
And so wherever we choose it,
that's going to be the length
of the left side of the stick.
And so because of this, we know
that the expectation of y
is just l/2, and the variance
of y is l squared over 12.
But unfortunately, calculating
the expectation variance of x
is not quite as simple, because
x isn't just uniformly
distributed between 0 and
some fixed number.
Because it's actually uniformly
distributed between
0 and y, wherever the
first break was.
But where the first break
is is random too.
And so we can't just say that
x is a uniformly distributed
random variable.
So what do we do instead?
Well, we'll make the nice
observation that let's pretend
that we actually
know what y is.
If we knew what y was, then
calculating the expectation of
x would be simple, right?
So if we were given that y is
just some little y, then x
would in fact just be uniformly
distributed between
0 and little y.
And then if that's the case,
then our calculation is
simple, because the expectation
of x would just be
y/2, and the variance would
just be y squared over 12.
All right, so let's make that
a little bit more formal.
What we're saying is that the
expectation of x, If we knew
what y was, would just be y/2.
And the variance of x If we knew
what y was would just be
y squared over 12.
All right, so notice
what we've done.
We've taken the second stage and
we've said, let's pretend
we know what happens in the
first stage where we break it.
And we know what y, the
first break, was.
Then the second stage becomes
simple, because the average of
x is just going to
be the midpoint.
Now what we do to calculate the
actual expectation of x,
well, we'll invoke the law
of iterated expectations.
So expectation of x is
expectation of the conditional
expectation of x given 1, which
in this case is just
expectation of y/2.
And we know what the expectation
of y is.
It's l/2.
And so this is just l/4.
l/4.
All right, and so notice
what we've done.
We've taken this calculation
and done it in stages.
So we assume we know where
the first break is.
Given that, the average location
of the second break
becomes simple.
It's just in the midpoint.
And then, we move up to
the higher stage.
And that now we average out
over where the first break
could have been.
And that gives us our
final answer.
And notice that this actually
makes sense, if we just think
about it intuitively, because
on average, the first break
will be somewhere
in the middle.
And then that will leave us with
half the stick left, and
we break it again.
On average, that will leave
us with another half.
So on average, you get a quarter
of the original stick
left, which makes sense.
All right, so that's the first
part, where we use the law of
iterated expectations.
Now, let's go to part B, where
we're actually asked to find
the variance.
The variance is given by the
law of total variance.
So let's do it in stages.
We'll first calculate the first
term, the expectation of
the conditional variance.
Well, what is the expectation
of the conditional variance?
We've already calculated
out what this
conditional variance is.
The conditional variance
is y squared over 12.
So let's just plug that in.
It's expectation of
y squared over 12.
All right, now this looks like
it could be a little difficult
to calculate.
But let's just first
pull out the 1/12.
And then remember, one way to
calculate the expectation of
the square of a random variable
is to use the variance.
So recall that the variance of
any random variable is just
expectation of the square
minus the square of the
expectation.
So if we want to calculate the
expectation of the square, we
can just take the variance
and add the square of the
expectation.
So this actually we can
get pretty easily.
It's actually just the variance
of y plus the square
of the expectation of y.
And we know what these
two terms are.
The variance of y is
l squared over 12.
And the expectation
of y is l/2.
So when you square that, you
get l squared over 4.
So l squared over 12 plus l
squared over 4 gives you l
squared over 3.
And you get that the first term
is l squared over 36.
All right, now let's calculate
the second term.
Second term is the variance of
the conditional expectation.
So the variance of expectation
of x given y.
Well, what is the expectation
of x given y?
We've already calculated that.
That's y/2.
So what we really want is
the variance of y/2.
And remember, when you have a
constant inside the variance,
you pull it out but
you square it.
So what you get is 1/4 the
variance of y, which we know
that the variance of y
is l squared over 12.
So we get that this is
l squared over 48.
OK, so we've calculated
both terms of
this conditional variance.
So all we need to do to
find the final answer
is just to add them.
So it's l squared over 36
plus l squared over 48.
And so, the final answer is
7 l squared over 144.
OK, and so this is the first,
the expectation of x, maybe
you could have guessed
intuitively.
But the variance of x is not
something that looks like
something that you could
have calculated off
the top of your head.
And so I guess the lesson from
this example is that it is
often very helpful if you
condition on some things,
because it allows you to
calculate things in stages and
build up from the bottom.
But it's important to note that
the choice of what you
condition on-- so the choice
of y-- is actually very
important, because you could
choose lots of other y's that
wouldn't actually
help you at all.
And so how to actually choose
this y is something that you
can learn based on just
having practiced with
these kinds of problems.
So again, the overall lesson
is, conditioning can often
help when you calculate
these problems.
And so you should look
to see if that could
be a possible solution.
So I hope that was helpful,
and see you next time.